します 今日のテーマは怒りというテーマでございまして
それについて時間の中でできるだけの内容をお話しさせていただきます
だといっても その問題について釈尊の教えは全部まとめて申し上げるわけにはいきませんし
大変たくさんいろんな教えがございますから
またそれ分析してみると
私たちは思うほどの簡単単純なことではないかもしれませんし
まあどうせ仏教の教えというのは
普通の人間の理解能力を乗り越えているものですから
あまり説明するとそれに怒ってしまう可能性もあります
ですから 日常必要なものだけ
説明したいと思っています
後ろの方々に聞こえないんでしょうか
このスピーカーを後ろに持っていけばいいんですけど
そういう持ち運ぶような感じがするかどうかはわからない
じゃあスピーカーなしに喋ります
機械に音を合わせると人間の耳に聞こえなくなるし
人間の耳に聞こえるように音を合わせると機械は狂ってしまいますし
どうしようかと そこには中道もないし
じゃあ最初にこの怒りという言葉を我々よく使っています
怒りというのは 船は使う錨ではないことはわかってますけど
でも怒りってどういうものかということは
やっぱりいくらか厳密に定義して理解した方がよろしいと思います
怒りというのは 愛情と同じく心にサッと現れてくる一つの感情なんです
私たちは自分の家族を見たり
自分好きな人を見たりすると
すぐ心の中で何か感情が
愛情という感情が生まれてくる
すぐそれ生まれてきます
何か美しいものを見ると
例えば美味しい何か召し上がると
口に入った時も 美味しい食べ物を見た時も
大変楽しい感情が生まれてきます
瞬時に起こるんです それと同時に
もう一つの人間の心に起こる感情は怒りというんです
ですから 大体我々には大雑把に言うと2種類の感情の 2種類の感情が生まれるみたいんです
一つは愛情の感情 もう一つは怒りの感情
ですから その 2つの感情で人間というのは生きているんです
今日はこの怒りの感情はどういうものかと
怒りというのは パーリ語でいろんな言葉
たくさんの言葉がございますが
一般的な言葉はドーサという言葉なんです
ドーサという言葉なんです
そのドーサという言葉の意味は
汚れるというふうな 濁るというんですか
そういうふうな意味なんで
いわゆる暗いという意味なんです
それの反対の言葉というと
やっぱり明るいという楽しいという意味になるんです
ですから 心にそのドーサという感情が汚れたような
濁ったような感情が生まれたら
確実に我々には何かを失うんです
失うものはピーティというんで
ハピネスなんです この
PITI ピーティ それは喜ぶ喜という漢字で書いても構いませんし
いわゆるハピネス喜びが心に消えるんです
心から消えてしまうんです
で 心にドーサドーサという怒りの感情が生まれたら
心から喜びというものが消えてしまう
ですから それは分かりやすい
私は怒っているかどうかと
なんか分からない場合は自分に聞いてみてください
私は楽しいですか？と
今は 今喜びを感じているんですか？と
そうすると別に楽しくはないんだと感じると
その時は怒りの感情があるんです
例えば 退屈だ つまらないんだ
嫌だなどの感情がある時は
心に怒りがあるんです
あ 楽しいんだ 幸せだ ワクワクしているんだというと
怒りはないんです 私は元気だと
そういうふうに言われるならば
その心に怒りがありません
なんかつまらないとと言われる人間の心の中に
その時は怒りというものはあります
そのように自分の心から生まれる怒りという感情をいくらか把握して勉強してみてください
で だいたいそれぐらいで怒りというものは認識できると思います
それから そういうものが強くなると
どんどん感情っていうのは強くなるんですね
強くなると働きも違うんだから
やっぱり違う言葉を使わなくちゃいけない
分かりやすく言えば 電気というものがありますし
電気はあっても別に大したことない
我々の体にも電気はありますけど
全然小さな豆電球一つもそれで
もう明るくすることはできないんですけど
でもその電気もいろんな形で集まると働きが変わってしまうんですね
例えば静電気として何百万ボルトぐらいの電圧があって
すごいエネルギーとして固まったら
我々にはありがたい雷という現象が生まれてくるんですね
雷も一応電気は電気なんですね
雷と店からコンビニエンスストアから買う乾電池ですか
単三電池 1個2個の電気は随分わけが違います
それは自分に体に入ったっても何の影響もない
でも この家の中に通っている電線を触ったり遊んだり見ると
火事になるかもしれません
自分が電気ショックで死ぬかもしれませんし
ですから電気は電気なんですけど
溜まってくると圧力が高くなっちゃうと
で ボルテージって何て言いますか
それはどんどん変わると働きが違うんです
そのように ちょっとつまらないなということも
大した怒りではないかもしれません
今日は退屈だと 退屈で退屈で
まあ嫌ですよという時も怒りなんですけど
だからといってもそんなに大変な問題ではないかもしれません
でも その怒りも電気と同じく
このどんどんこの電圧ですか
怒り圧ですか それはもうどんどん高くなっちゃうと
これ危ないんです 自分が爆発してしまうか
他人にそれ怒りのショック与えて
他人までそれで壊してしまう可能性はあります
ですからこのその場合は違ういろんな言葉を使っているんです
で 例えば怒りは すごく力強くなって
なんか自分の歯もじりじりと噛みたくなるし
手の指なんかこうやってきつく捻ったりするし
筋肉が揺れるように震えるようになってくると
我々はヴェーラという言葉を使うんです
これはサンスクリット語でワイラという言葉なんです
まだたくさん言葉がございますけどね
まあそこら辺に 置いておきましょう
2つぐらいの言葉で で
とにかくそのこの感情
この暗い感情 幸福が失った感情
失われた感情 不幸を感じる感情があまり強烈になると
ヴェーラというレベルに上がってきて
まあじっとしていられない
さらに強くなっちゃうといろいろ行動する
それでまあいろんなものを破壊していく
一番先に破壊するのは自分なんですね
自分を破壊して それでも他人を破壊していきいくんです
で 他の言葉で言えば この世の中の破壊の元素ですか
破壊の原因は怒りなんですね
世の中のものは出来上がったりする
創造の泉は怒りではなくて愛情であって
創造したものは壊していくのは
破壊していくのは怒りの感情なんです
それは普遍的な世の中にある種類のエネルギーの流れなんです
ですから ひいて言えば一つのセットなんです
愛情と怒りで ヒンドゥー教という宗教では
このブラフマンは創造するする
それからシヴァという神が破壊する
ちゃんと二つに分けてます
それはもう神が全部やってると思ってますから
まあ世の中にそういう二つのエネルギーの流れがあります
とにかく じゃあもうちょっと仏教的な定義がございます
仏教では残念ながらこのこの人間の感情は人格化しようとしないんです
人格化した方が人間には分かりやすいんですよ
でも仏教ではそれを人格化しようとしない
で 例えば愛情は人格化して神と呼ぶし
憎しみやら嫉妬やら怒りやら
そういうものは人格化して悪魔という
そうすると人間はやっぱり神様を拝まなくちゃ
悪魔と戦わなくちゃという風に
なんか誰か頭の中でそうそうイメージを作って行動します
それですごくわかりやすい
それで神はいるかいないか
神は悪魔はいるかいないかとか
いろんなことを考えたり
哲学したり 無駄な時間使ってます
で わかりやすいんだから
それでいろんな人間の感情をそういうふうに人格化するんです
で 怒りは人格化するし
憎しみは人格化するし
嫉妬人格化しているし
それからいい人間の感情も
愛やらなんだかんだも人格化するということがございますが
仏教ではそうはしません
なぜかというと 一番最初に分かりやすくしようと思う
人格化したっても 結局人間はそういうものは自分と別に存在しているんだと
悪魔に自分が誘惑されているんだと
と言って 他人のせいにして自分をいい子にする
要するに私が悪いんじゃなくて
悪魔に誘惑されているんだと
そういうふうにして 何か自分の心を見ようとはしない
それはもう大間違いであって
ですから 人格化しないように気を付けて
科学的に分析してみなさいということはあるんです
それはもちろん難しいんです
理解するのは 科学的には
仏教の心理学的に怒りを解釈するとこういうことなんです
例えば 私たちは目を開けて何かを見る
その見た時は綺麗なバラの花一本見える
見えたらどんな感情が生まれるかというと
あ 花だ 綺麗だという楽しい感情が生まれてくる
それは愛情の感情 それでまた目を開けた途端
そのバラの花の上にでかいゴキブリが座っている
その瞬間でああ嫌だ 気持ち悪いんだと
という感情が生まれてくる
それは怒りの感情 誰のせいにすればいいんですかね
その場合は 私の怒り 怒れ生まれたのはこのとんでもないゴキブリのせいだと
悪いのはゴキブリだと
犯人はゴキブリだと ふうに決めるかと
あるいは犯人は自分自身かと決めるかと
そこは何とかしなくちゃいけない
とにかくそこにどういうことをどういうプロセスですかと聞くと
見ると花を見るとその対象は受け入れる
あいい綺麗だ だから欲しいんだと
見たいんだという acceptance 受け入れる
ある対象は 私たちは心の中に来てちょうだいと受け入れる
それは acceptance ね
英語で 英語の言葉要りませんだけど
なんも言えないんですけど
こういうことも あるいはacceptだけでもいいです
もしかするとaccept受け入れる
で ゴキブリが目に入ったら我々は拒否する
否定する reject
その感情は我々は拒否します
見たくない 嫌です 出て行け
いてはほしくないと ですから
じゃあこのacceptance reject
という 2つの働き 受け入れることと拒否することは誰がやってるんですか
それは我々は目で物を見て
耳で音を聞いて 体に世の中のことを触れたりすると
そうしている 私たちがしているんです
もし対象が受け入れたら愛情が生まれてくるわ
拒否したら怒りが生まれてくるわ
それはですから その個人の人格なんです
より明るく生きているか
あるいは苦しくて悔しくて
もう文句言いながら文句だらけの人生になるかというのは
その人の個人差であります
なぜならば バラの花は私を綺麗だと見てくださいと頼んでいるわけじゃないんです
ただ自分の姿勢で咲いているだけで
人間何を思おうが バラの花には何の関係もないんです
かえって迷惑ですからね
綺麗だと思ってもらって
自分 植物としての自分の命は
正しく生きていられなくなっているんだから
ですから それ綺麗だと思ったのは人間の勝手であって
ゴキブリは気持ち悪いと思ったのは
それまた人間の勝手であって
ゴキブリっていうのはそんなに醜い酷いもんであるならば
例えば鳥なんかはニワトリでもいいんだけど
皆さん見たことがないんだけど
ニワトリなんか結構ゴキブリ食べますけど
ニワトリなんかゴキブリ見たらどう思いますか？というと
あ これ美味しいんだ 食べてやろうと言って
そこにacceptanceということ現象が生まれるんです
そこでニワトリがバラの花見たら
なんかすまらない 面倒くさい
迷惑やと そこでニワトリにはrejectionという感情が
怒りが生まれてくる 私はバラの花を見て愛情が生まれるのであって
ニワトリには怒りが生まれるんであって
ゴキブリを見た私が怒るんであって
ゴキブリを見たニワトリが愛情が生まれてきて
食べよう 美味しいんじゃないかという感じが生まれていて
それは世の中にある事実ですから
そこで怒りの感情生まれるのも
愛情の感情生まれるのも
我々の個人の人格であることを理解してほしいんです
それは同じ人間の中でも同じなんです
で そういう一般的に見れば
どんな人間でも花は綺麗と思うかもしれませんだけど
例えば食べ物やら服装ですか
着るもののデザインとか
そういうものに考えちゃうと
また文化的にいろいろ差があるんですよ
例えば女性は体は見せてはいけないと
それは醜いんだと 隠した方が綺麗やと思っている文化もありまして
その文化ではもう体の 75%ぐらい外へ出して服
服着ている人々を見ると
みんな気持ち悪がる そこで体はできるだけ見せるようにした方が綺麗と思っている文化では
ああ すごい綺麗だ 美人だとかっこいいんだと思っちゃう
もしかすると この何でしたっけ
この中東の国々では 女性は顔も隠しちゃいますからね
黒い何かもうヴェールみたいなものを着て
もう顔も全部隠して 手ここだけしか外に出してないんですね
であれも中はいっぱいおしゃれしてますよ
いっぱい金のネックレスやらもう金のネックレスやらあだこだと
見えない誰にも あれ見てそちらの男性たちが
あ 綺麗な女性だなと思っているかもしれません
私たちがこれおばあちゃんか女の子か
どっちかさっぱりわからない
みんな同じ 顔も見え見えないんだから
何のために綺麗に生まれたんですかと
私たちの文化からそう思うかもしれません
ですから そこでその文化によってもう決まることはそれぞれ勝手なんです
例えば日本で伊勢エビなんかはそのままいけす作りにして
刺身にして いろいろ綺麗に作ってテーブルの上に置いておけば
エビさんのなんて言いますかね
アンテナみたいなもの
何かあるんで そういうものはもうまだまだ動いている
目はじりじりとじろじろとあっちこっち見ている
でも体は全部 もう切って切って
ギザギザに切って もう刺身にしているんですよ
それを見て 日本のグルメの方々はものすごい感動する
ああ 美味しいんだと まだ食べてもないんだけど
ああ 幸福だと それはまあインドやら我々私たちの国々の人々に見せてください
美味しいところから逃げるんですよ
まあ二度とその人の家でご飯も食べないかもしれません
あまりにも恐ろしくて
ですから だからどういうふうに感情が生まれるかというと
それその文化やら育ちやらね
そういうことであって
そこでそんな残酷 残酷なことをするするんですかという仏陀の考え方であって
こちらでは まあこれは生け簀だから一番最高級の食べ物だと
こちらでそういうふうに教え込まれてあって
だからこちらでは愛情が生まれる
向こうの人にとっては強烈な拒絶反応が生まれる
テレビでやるみたいなこと
アフリカかどこかでも
田舎のものすごい田舎の山の中で
もう文明から離れて生活する誰かを日本に連れてきて
日本で落ちて精一杯向こうは贅沢何もしませんだから山の中でどこかで寝るだけで精一杯面倒見てあげようと思って
何かタイですかなんかすっごいでっかい魚をそのまま作って
それは名誉料理なんですね
置いといたところで家族みんな来ていたんですね
山の中で全く原始的な生活をしているのに
あれを見たらもう食欲がなくなっちゃって
みんなあっち見て持って行ってください
持って行ってくださいと
特に男の子がいたんです
まあ歳ぐらいかな すごい厳しく
もう見たくもない 持っていってくださいと
で どうしようもなくそれをまあ持っていったんです
また台所に ですから そこでその感情がね
そのその人々によっても変わります
だから怒るのも愛情が作るのも
このそれぞれの個人の勝手だよということを
まずご理解していただけなきゃ困るんです
誰のせいでも怒るわけじゃなくて
私は私のせいで怒っているんだと
ということは 我々にはわずかな見込みというか
光があるんです 自分を直せば
怒りの感情を完璧になくしてしまって
愛情の感情 あるいは幸福の感情で生きていられる可能性は思い存分あります
それで我々の教育とか育てられる文化とか
そういう影響もあります
で マスコミから流れてくる情報も
そういうものからも 我々の善悪判断とかね
ものを認識することとか
そういうのはコントロールされてますから
マインドコントロールされてますから
そちらへも少々考えておいた方がいいんです
ということは まあえーと
これは今流行ってるんだとか
今この色はもうもうダサいとか言われると
いかに美しい色であろうとも
それを見ると気持ち悪くなるとか
ひどい あまりにも綺麗でもない色なのに
あ これは今流行ってるんだと言われると
あ 綺麗綺麗だと見てしまうと
例えば色の中でも何のおもしろくない色っていうのは黒い色なんですよ
あれ随分かっこいいと
最近もうみんな着るようになったんだから
ですから その時代になると
まあ今流行ってるのはこの色だというと
みんなこの見る角度を変えて
あ 綺麗だ美しいんだと思って
その愛情の感情を作る
まあそれで怒りの定義
そこら辺に終わります
で 怒りというのはどういうものかというと
我々は見るもの 聞くもの
味わうもの 嗅ぐもの それから考えるものについて
それを拒否する 嫌だと思う
それから怒りが生まれる
その拒否したがるエネルギー
これは食べたくないんだとか
あの人とはしゃべりたくないんだとか
あっちは行きたくないんだというふうな出てくるエネルギーに怒りと言うんです
それは強烈になるとひどいもんですよ
あの人とはしゃべりたくないとか
付き合いたくないとかいうと
もうわずかなエネルギーで見たくもないと
いてもほしくないと思っちゃうと
すごい強烈なエネルギーなんですね
それどんどんエスカレートして
その人は自分には見えなくなっても
どこかにいるんだから
元気で それはもう それも我慢できないと思っちゃうと
何とかしてその人を殺してしまうんですね
ですから そういう人を殺すところまで怒りがエスカレートするんです
自然も社会も何でも破壊するところまで
それはエスカレートするんです
ですから 怒りというのは拒否する心の中で生まれてくる
感情ですね で こういう定義から
我々にはできれば自分を直せば
自分を直せば その問題から何とか逃れられることができるということだけ言います
それから問題は それ自然的な生まれる感情であるならば
花を見たら綺麗と思う
ゴキブリ見たらもう嫌だと思う
それは普通ではないかと
死んでいる 死んでもうさばいている豚の肉を見たら
ああ 美味しいと思ったりするし
同じく蛇なんか殺してもうぶつ切りにして見て
ああ気持ち悪いと思ったりするでしょうに
そうするとそれは自然的だからいいんじゃないかと
例えば日本では結構豚肉食べますけど
豚肉と一緒に豚の頭そのまま丸ごと
あの 何て言いますか このロースティングという
なんとか焼くでしょうに
焼いて丸ごと豚の頭なんかテーブルに持ってきたら
あんまりいい気持ちにならないでしょ
例えばそういう日本でも食べるところありますけど
あまり東京なんかはあまり見えません
豚の足でもその足でそのまんま料理してあると
なんか食べる気にはならない
別に理由あるわけじゃないんです
だから自然だから 人間だから怒るのは人間だからではないか
愛情も人間だからではないかと思って無視しちゃえばどうですかねと
そのままでいいんじゃないかと
しょうがない これ本能だから
それも一つの人間の考え方なんですよ
怒るのもしょうがない
人間だから怒るのは当たり前だと
ですから 自分のことを私もすぐ怒りますよ
しょうがない 私の本能だから
言って諦めて開き直って
そのままでいればどうですかと
まあそう決めちゃえば一応ややこしくはないんだけどね
何もしなくていいんだから
そのままでいいんだよ
それだったら でも問題は
もしある人が率直 怒れるような
怒るような性格であるならば
その人は一生何を感じていますか？不幸を感じているんです
喜びは全く感じないんです
せっかく人間に生まれたのに
人生は不幸 文句だらけの人生
わずかな喜びも感じない
ちょっとかわいそうじゃないですか
それはその人の性格だから
あんたの性格だからいいんですよと許してあげたっても
やっぱりかわいそうでしょうに
生きる喜びというものもありますから
仕事をする喜び 子供育てる喜び
元気で頑張る喜び みんなと仲良くする喜びとか
また喜びもこの世の中にありますから
美味しいご飯を食べて喜んだりするし
どこか旅行行って喜んだり楽しがったりするし
綺麗な服を着ておしゃれをしてそれで喜んだりするし
そうすると そのすべての喜びはその人には関係なくなっちゃう
文句だらけの人と一緒に旅行でも行ってみてください
こちらまでいら立つほど
その人はあっちにあれに文句
これに文句が文句だけで
何一つも喜びを感じないんです
文句だらけの人と一緒にどこか食事にでも行ってみてください
文句 文句 文句であって
何一つも周りから喜びを感じようとしない
ですから不幸だけなんです
そういう人々は幸福感じる人々にとっても結構迷惑なんです
ですから これ本能だと思って放っておくわけにはいきません
で 人間幸福を感じるのは
もし悪いことであるならば怒った方がいいんですけど
でも この苦しい人生の中で
我々にはわずかな 1滴の
喉が渇いている時は 1滴の水でもありがたいんでしょうに
そこで生きることは大変であって
体を支えているのはもう大変ですから
それでわずかな 1滴の水のように
我々にはもうあっちこっちでちょっとした喜びがあります
仕事は苦しくたっても
なんとなく仕事をしていると
なんとなく仕事をしているんだという充実感
幸福感もあります 子供育てるのはものすごい大変なことなんですけど
そこでまた私の子供ですよと
可愛いんですよという
そこに愛情もまたあります
喜びもあります だから頑張れるでしょうし
それも捨ててしまえば人間には生きていられなくなるんです
ですから 怒りという感情をコントロールした方が
我々の幸福のためになります
みんなの幸福のためになります
ですから こういう風に聞けばどうでしょうか
どうでしょうかと 人間はなぜ幸福感じるのは悪いんですかね
なんで楽に生きていられるのは悪いんですかね
なんで何を見たっても
すごく楽しく明るく どんなものにもアプローチするのは悪いんですかね
山に行ったら山を楽しむし
東京に行ったら東京の都会人生ですか
それを楽しむと 海に行ったら海を楽しむと
そういう生き方は本当に悪いんですかと
決して悪いとは思えないんですよ
例えば 仕事はすごく楽しくする
それで休みがもらった瞬間
休みを楽しむ そうすると
ずっと人生っていうのは幸福
楽しみの人生になるんです
人間っていうのは 例えば都会は嫌だという人は
都会にいると苦しみや怒りを感じて
田舎に行って楽しみを感じる
田舎はいいんだとか そこで田舎はもう苦労ばっかしで
買い物もできないし あまり何て言いますか
刺激もないし 遊ぶところもないんだからつまらないんだと
田舎に住んで怒りを感じる人々もいるし
そういう人は東京に来て楽しむんだと
それもその人々は幸福の一部消しているんですよ
削っているんです 私は今そうじゃなくて
田舎に行ったら田舎を楽しんで
東京に来たら東京を楽しめばどうですか？と
子供が家にいて ものすごく大騒ぎ状態だったら
それみんなと大騒ぎすることを楽しがって
後でみんな大きくなって家を出て
自分一人ぼっちで老夫婦だけになったところで
その静けさを楽しめばどうですかね
そうすると全部楽しいでしょうし
普段は我々はもう心の中で決めつけて
これは私の幸福だと何か厳密に決めつけている
それある限りは幸福だ幸福だと思っちゃう
なくなったらものすごい不幸になってしまう
それもあるんです 例えば子供
子供を育てることは私の生きがいだよと言って元気に活動する女性の方々は
その子供はみるみるうちに大きくなって成長して独立して出ていくでしょうに
そうすると強烈に不幸を感じる
ものすごく寂しくて やることがなくて
生きがいがなくなっちゃって
それから怒りだけ 強烈な不幸
それで文句言い始めるんですよ
私は子供をこれまで育てたのに
こういうこういうことをしてあげたのに
今は私のこと見ようともしないんだとか
あーだこーだ 嫁をいじめるは
もう義母さんをいじめるは
もう片っ端から世の中をいじめて
社会からももう嫌な嫌な人やと思われて
それから自分の体はどんどん病気になってしまって
ひどい不幸は味わうんですよ
それは男性にも同じくありまして
仕事は生きがいだと思っている男性の方々は
仕事終わったところでやることがなくて
みるみるうちに死んでいっちゃうんです
体が病気になって不幸になるんです
ですから 正しいじゃなくて
よりいい方法っていうのは
この何があろうと我々はそれは拒否する感情ではなくて
受け入れて その状況を楽しむではないかと
そうすると 仕事あるならば仕事を楽しむ
仕事を終わってから老後を楽しむと
孫が来たら孫と遊んでそれを楽しむ
それで一日孫と遊んじゃったら
まあ体がグタグタもう疲れますからね
その孫が帰っちゃったら
ああ寂しいやとかやじゃなくて
やっと自分の時間に戻ったんだから
ゆっくり休むのではないか
楽しく休めばそこでまた楽しさが生まれてくるんです
孫にあっちに引っ張られてこっちに引っ張られて
もう大変でしたと 今日はもうゆっくりのんびり生活できるんだと
そういうどんな状況はどのように変えても
その状況を拒否しない
否定しない心育てれば
そこに怒りの生まれる余地もないし
人間に幸福というものはものすごく味わえるんです
ですから 怒りは本能だと
だからしょうがないやと思って甘えるのは危険な道なんです
それを甘えるというよりは怠けることなんです
自分のことをまあいいんじゃないかと努力しないことだから
それ不放逸です 不放逸
放逸ですか 怠けは それは放逸という仏教用語がございますけど
そういうふうにまあ怠けて生活しちゃうと
それは危険なんです ですから
怒りとは戦うと それまた怒りですから
怒りを戦うんではなくて
まあなんとかして怒れない
怒れないような人格の育ち方した方がよろしいということなんです
で 怒りは感情だから 本能だからしょうがないと放っておくと
今の世の中はそのまんまなんです
今の世の中はみんな怒りを放っておいているんです
だから我々は今 我々の命さえ危機にさらされているんです
本当に生きていられるかと不安でしょうがないんですよ
食べる食べ物は本当に体にいいかどうかがわからないんです
この吸ってる空気は汚染しているかいないかわからないんです
飲んでる水は本当に飲めるか飲めないかと
これ知ったもんじゃないんです
今 日に当たる太陽に当たることも怖いんです
ですから このあまりにも破壊的な行動したりして
それでどこでどんな瞬間で戦争が起こるかわからない
人間 どんどん武器を作ったり研究したりしている
地球の財産のもう 60%以上武器の開発に使っているし
人を殺すために ちょっとでもそういうものは使うようになったら
人類はそれで終わりし
使わなくたっても そういうのを人間が作る機械だからどうせ信頼できない
そういうのを自動的に何とかで起動しちゃったらどうするんですかね
今 ほとんどの武器っていうのは遠隔操作というか
このリモートコントロールシステムで使ってるんだから
こちらから電波信号を送ったところであの爆弾が自分で起動して出て行っちゃうんだから
今 ありとあらゆる電波だらけだから
汚染のあそこでもう空気が乱れたり
いろんなことしたり もしそういう電波をあまりにも受け入れて混乱しちゃう
その機械自体があっちこっちで自動的に爆発しちゃったらどうするんですかと
そういうのは絶対ありえませんというのはもう絶対嘘であって
日本の同年とかなんとかとか
それは世界一標準高く安全だというのは真っ平な嘘であって
かなり汚染しているんです
ですから そういう人々の言うのは全然信じない方がいいんです
ですから やっぱり世の中は怒りというものを放っておくということは
やっぱり我々の命に関わるものなんです
ですから 怒りをコントロールした方が幸福になる道であります
それはですから このあまり自分に甘えないで
怒りが生まれないように我々は性格を調整すること
怒りと戦うということじゃないんです
それは悪に向かって戦おうと
正義の味方になろうというのは仏教ではありません
それは違う人々の考え方なんです
正義の味方とか この正義の味方
何をするんですかというと
悪人を倒すと 人を倒したり殺したりするための必要なのは何でしょうかというと
怒りなんです ということは
正義の味方という仮面の裏で怒りを正当化しているんです
でも 法則として見ると怒りは良くないんです
それは拒絶する 拒否する反応だから
ですから 正義の味方は敵を探していく
歩き回るんです 悪人を
倒そうと ですから 何とかに向かって戦おうとかね
という感情っていうのはまったくけしからんな感情で
そういうことで人間 子供たちを生かされると
確実にそういう人々はすごいストレス溜まって
ものすごい問題を作りますよ
勉強にしても戦おうではないかと
そうするとそこに怒りなんですよ
なんで戦うんですか で
うまくいかない 苦しくなってしまう
ですから この仏教では
この正しい怒りっていうのは絶対ありえないんです
なし どんな怒りでも正当化するのは不可能なんです
それを怒るのは当たり前だよと言えません
で あの大乗仏教の一つのテキストがございまして
このシャンティデワという人がボーディチャリアタラという書きた
ずいぶん昔書いたあの
本なんですけど そこはまあ歌ですけど
菩薩の心のことを書いてあってから
発心ですか そういう菩薩の心はどうやって生まれますかというテキストで
まあ言舞もありますけど
そこに菩薩は世の中のために
人 世直しのために 人々のために行動するものでありと
それで菩薩はこう考えるんですね
じゃあ私はこの悪い連中を倒せればどうですかと
世の中に悪いことをするは
もう悪ばっかり起こしたりするわ
そういう連中は片っ端からなくしちゃえばどうですか
いわゆる悪い人は殺せばどうですかと
いたってもみんなに迷惑だから
みんなのために そしたら菩薩はこう考えるんですね
そう思って私はどれぐらい人を殺せばいいんですかと
どれぐらい生命を殺せばいい
すべての生命を殺さなくちゃいけないんだと
それだったら それよりその人を倒したいと
殺したいという私の心だけ直せばいいんじゃないかと
ですからそこで言っているのは
この人間の心にそういう考え方あるんですよ
あの人悪人だから死んで当然だと
そうすると悪人みんな死んで当然だと思ったら
もうどれぐらい死ねばいいんですかね
結局それも殺戮というんですか
この人類の全体的な破壊でしょうに
じゃあ完璧な善人がいるんですかね
完璧な人だからいてもいいやと
あなたは悪いことするんだからもう死んでもいいと
そういうのは完全たるヘリクツですね
ですから正しい怒りというものは全くない
殺してもいいという人はどこにもいません
いるはずがないんです
例えば 不正的な行動をするならば
政治家として不祥しくないと決めて追い出してみてください
国から政治家が亡くなっちゃうんです
人よりも で そんなものになるんですよ
それあのイエス様の世界で一応ストーリーがありましたね
あの 何て言いますか 不倫をしたらもう石でぶん殴って殺すというストーリーがありました
そこでユダヤの人々が女の人を捕まえて
柱に縛って たくさん石を持ってきて
みんなで集めて じゃあ石を投げてその女の人を殺しましょうと
死刑に決まってるんですね
不倫したんだから そこにイエス様が行く
で あんた方は何をしようとしているんですか？ったら
ラッバイ この人は不倫したんだと
旦那を裏切ったと ですから
我々の伝統的な宗教の神様の教えによって
その人はもう石で殴って殺すべきですよと
我々はちゃんと神様の
何と言いますか 戒めの通りにその人を処刑にしますと
イエス様何言ったんだよ
よし 分かりました 最初の石は何も罪を犯してない人は投げてくださいと
最初の石 それだけ 誰も最初の石を取らないんです
それであの女性の命はやっと助かってもらったんです
それは事実ですから 悪いことをしたんだからといって
その人に何か何とかしてもいいという概念というのは
本当におかしいんです
ですから キリスト教徒ってのは許してあげてください
許してあげてください
じゃあどこまで許すんですかというと
どこまででも許してあげてくださいと
それにはもうリミットがない
その教えはその通り正しいんですよ
それで幸福が得られると
神の世界が自分に現れるんだと
神の世界というのは幸福という状態だから
すべては許す気持ちになったら
一切を許してあげる 人は何をしようとも
どうなろうとも 私はその人を許してあげますと
私はその人に対して直接反応を起こしませんと
私はその人に対して愛情がわきますというと
その人の心は愛情だけで幸福だけで一体になってしまうんです
それはキリスト教で神と言うし
他の宗教で他の言葉で言うし
それはあまり大したことじゃないんです
そういうことで 怒りっていうのは何とかした方がいいということを放っておいてはいけないと
それから怒りに我々に何のいろんな影響を与えてくれるんですね
1番目の影響はもう説明しました
不幸になる それは分かりやすいんです
怒ってると気持ちいいんですか？と言えば気持ち悪いんだから
退屈な時は本当に気持ちいいんですか？最低でしょうに
その時は気持ちは お清くしている時どうですか
気持ちは ものすごい幸福でしょうに
何かやることがあるとすごい気持ちいいでしょうに
ですから 怒りっていうのは不幸ですから
それは一番目 それで怒りっていうのはこの拒否する
捨てるエネルギーなんです
壊すエネルギーなんです
破壊力なんです ネガティブエネルギーなんです
創造のエネルギーではないんです
愛情っていうのはクリエイティブエネルギーなんです
クリエーション 怒りはディストラクション
英語の言葉でクリエイティブとディストラクティブ
そこで愛情が生まれてくると
クリエイティブエネルギーは創造する
何か作る 育てる そういう喜びの感情で
怒りが生まれたらディストラクティブ
破壊するエネルギーが
ネガティブエネルギーが生まれている
それでこれ考えましょう
怒りはどこに生まれますかというと
この体に この自分の体に生まれるんです
破壊するために必要なのは火なんですね
一般的に言うと で ヒンドゥーのシヴァ神は火の神様なんです
ですから シヴァ神を称える時は火を
火を作って それにいろんな儀式
宗教儀式 儀礼やっているのは
皆様テレビで見たことがあると思います
よく考えたもんですよ
シヴァ神にお供えしたい
それで火を作って 聖なる火を作って
それに食べ物をあげたりして
神様どうそう食べてくださいと
で そこに象徴的に火は破壊するんだからと
で 仏教でもこれを火に例えているんです
怒りっていうのは で この体に火を燃えたら何でも火をつけて破壊することはできます
が 先にどうなるんですかと
自分が燃えているんですね
ですから 怒りは破壊するし
先に破壊するのは自分なんです
自分を先に破壊してしまう
マッチの場合も同じでしょうに
私はこのゴミを燃やしましょうと思って
マッチを取って火をつける
先に燃えてしまうのはどっちですかね？マッチ自体でしょうに
マッチは大事なものだから
それは破壊しませんようにと
なくならないようにと
でもゴミを燃やしてほしいと
ということはありえないでしょう
だから我々は怒りを作ったということは
自分を燃やし始めたということ
全部細胞破壊になっちゃうんです
ぐちゃぐちゃになっちゃうんです
あの ちょっと野菜でも何でも
わずかな火に わずかな熱に当ててみてください
太陽でもいいんです すごくこのみずみずしい香り
香りじゃなくてきれいな色の野菜なんかは外に置いてみてください
そこで太陽から火が 熱が入るでしょ
一時間 二時間 三時間置いておけば
それから取ってみると
全部もう枯れたような状態で
その状態は まあただそれ火だからわかりますよ
でも同じこと我々の体の中に起こるんです
よく怒りの感情ある人はすぐ先に老けちゃうんです
早く年取るんです 早くも体が悪くなっちゃうんです
一番先に効くのはそれ
このすごい柔らかい内臓なんですよ
なぜならば内臓なんかはずっと仕事をしなくちゃいけない
我々の心臓にしたっても
肺にしたっても またいろいろありますけど
名前は忘れましたけどね
腎臓やらいろいろありますね
パンクレアスとかギャザーとか
で 例えば脳細胞もね 特にこのいろんなこのホルモン出している脳の中にも見えぬほど小さい
いろんな機械というか器官がありますよ
すごく柔らかく すごく小さくて
そういうものは２４時間前働いています
だから手に何か痛く出て
あっ手は痛くなったと怒ったらというような
そんなことがないんだけど
もし怒った瞬間で手が強烈に痛くなったりとか
足が痛くて動かなくなったとか
もうお腹が強烈に痛くてもう死にそうになったということがあるならば
人は怒りませんだけど
でも怒りっていうのはものすごいもっと恐ろしいんです
我々はすぐ感じない 内臓とこのホルモン関係のすべての機械を燃やしちゃうんです
その細胞を早く老化するんです
それで知らないうちにじわじわとあっちこっち痛みが出てくるわ
痒いとなったりするわ
腸やら全部もう早くも知らないうちにすぐがんになってるわとか
で 治り難い病気になります
だからこのすごい病気に悩んでる人々は
本当は性格的にはかなり怒りの性格を持っている
文句だらけの性格を持っている
明るくて明るくて嫌なほど明るい人々は病気になったっていうことはほとんど少ないんです
病気になったっても もうあんまりもうお医者さんもその人と喋るのは好きで
もうもうすぐ治ってしまうんです
明るい人は病院に入院したっても
みんな楽しくて 看護婦さんたちもお医者さんみんな
そうすると早く治るし
ものすごい親切に面倒見てくれるし
何のことはない それで患者さんが随分みんなに嫌われちゃうのは文句言う患者さんでしょうに
あれはいけない これはいけない
こうなってはいけない
ああしなさい こうしなさいとか
それで看護婦さんもあんなうるさい患者さんがまたもう何て言いますか
あの コーリングベルですか
呼び いや また呼び出してるんだとか
呼び出したら行かなくちゃいけないし
行ったら何ですかって
いえ ちょっとこのもう掛け布団をちょっとかけてちょうだいとか
またあれを鳴らしたりして
この水をちょっとここに置いておいてくださいとか
まあどうでもいいことにもずっと
それでそんな呼ばなくてもいいんではない？と言ったら
いえ そいつらの仕事だから
呼んだら来るのが仕事では
そういう態度で それで病気治せますかね
治らないんです それで延々と苦しむんです
病院の寿命は 病院の生活は長くなるわ
いればいるほどみんなに嫌われるわ
それでどんどんお医者さんもただ儀式儀礼で見るわ
儀式決まってるわ 薬はこれとこれと
もう決まるわ それからどうでもいい
もう早く逃げようと 看護婦さんもその時その時の面倒を見て
もう早く逃げようという気持ちで
気持ちは伝わってないし
それですごく苦しんじゃうんですね
ですから 怒りの 怒りの場合は何もいいことはないんです
生まれた瞬間に 体には強烈な猛毒が入っちゃうんです
ということで たとえわずかでも怒るのは良くない
体には で それはまず言ったら自分燃やしてしまう
自分早く病気になる それからこの怒りというものは
この怒りも人間の感情っていうのはすぐ他の感情と合わせてしまうんです
私たちというのはものすごい弱いもんで
すぐ周りの影響を受けてしまっちゃうんです
例えば子供が泣いていると
なんかすごい親お母さんと喧嘩して
なんとか欲しいものがあっても買ってくれないんだから喧嘩してすごく泣いてるんだと
その場合は何か他のこと言ってあげて
なんか他の面白いことを言って
なんとか言ってみてください
何のことなく すぐもう泣き止めてもう笑い出しちゃいますから
あれすぐ忘れてしまっちゃいます
そういうことは子供だけじゃなくて
大人にも誰にでもありますよ
例えば我々でも もうなんか例えばうちに帰ったら奥さんと喧嘩になったと
言ったらもうスルスルとどこか出かけてしまう
どこか面白いところに行く
飲み屋さんやら海やらどこか行って
その時間そこでいるとどうなるんですかね
うちでカンカン怒ってたのに
外へ出た途端もう怒りがサーッと消えてしまうんです
何のことなく ということは
我々はいつでも環境から影響を受けてるんです
そこでみんな楽しく遊んでるところに
ものすごく怒ってる人を入れてみてください
そしたらあの楽しさ 全部消えちゃうんです
例えば あるところで若者が踊ってるんだと
ディスコなんかは そこで誰がいきなりこれは何やってるんですか？とか
てめえらとかとか そういうきつい言葉で喋ったりする一人の人だけ入ったとしましょう
40人の人々は遊んでいるんです
どうなるんですかね 40
人の喜びがサッと消えちゃうんです
それはちゃんと理解させてほしい
私が自分で怒ってるだけではなくて
体から強烈なこの放射能みたいな
このものすごい恐ろしい波動を出して
すべての人々の幸福を奪ってしまう
社会の幸福も壊してしまう
恐ろしい鬼 恐ろしい悪魔になるんです
そういうわけで 自分 自分だけ知るんだったらもう勝手にしてちょうだいと言えますけど
そうは言っていられないんです
それ怒る連中が 怒る人々はみんなに限りなく迷惑をかけているんです
みんなの幸福も奪っちゃうんです
大泥棒なんですよ 人間というのは幸福を味わいたくて必死に必死なのに
せっかく得た幸福もすぐ取っていっちゃいます
取っていくんじゃなくて壊してしまうんです
取っていくんだったら別に気にしないことだっていいんです
例えばまあ誰かが来て
自分がせっかく食べようと思ってたご飯を持って行って自分で食べたんだと
まあそれぐらい まあいいわ
食べてくださいと というぐらい気持ちになりますからね
これ食べた人はこれすごい美味しかったよと
もし言ってくれたら あの悔しさ消えちゃうんですよ
自分が作ったものを自分で食べたかったんだけど
これ奪われて誰か食べて
あ これはすごい美味しいんだと
また作ってくださいと言われちゃうと
私がその幸福なくなっても
私にその幸福なくなっても
この人はすごく喜んで食べちゃったんだからまあいいんじゃないかと
ですから その奪う方は別にそんなに気にしなくてもいいんですよ
いわゆるそれも泥棒といえば泥棒なんですけど
そういう泥棒は幸福を奪うんじゃないんです
怒りの人は我々の大事な
生命に一番大事なものを奪うんです
いわゆる生命を殺すんです
だから破壊力なんです
人間に生きがいをなくしてしまうんです
国の政治をやってる人々は怒ってしまえば
誰かに向いて その国は戦争に巻き込まれちゃうんです
ここみんな行って戦争して死ななくちゃいけないんです
世の中を歴史見ると そういう愚か者どもが
確実に愚か者に限るんですよ
この政治やりたいと 王になりたい
独裁者になりたいと と思うのは
智慧のある人はそんなくだらないことをやりたくないんだと
とやりませんだけど ですから
昔から今までも世の中を支配しているのは
まあ決して知識人でもなし
天才たちでもなく 悪人なん
まあそんなに気つく思なくてもいいんだけど
あまりこの心は良くない
そういう人々はいつ頭が狂っちゃうかわからないんです
大変なんですよ 例えばある国の大統領がいるとすると
その人をコントロールするためにも
何百人も人々やら大勢の人々が周りにいるんですよ
それぐらい危ないんです
ちょっと自分の意思でなんか判断しちゃったら
ですからもう周りはいっぱい知識人やらいろんな人々が
人々がいて その人はじゃあこれはこの場合はこうします
この場合はこうしますと
例えばこういう大きな国の大統領誰か喋るたちが喋る時は
喋る文章を言葉ずつ言葉ずつ書いてあげるんです
そこでなんか偉そうに自分が読むだけ
それぐらいコントロールしておかないとどうするかわからない
恐ろしい ですから この怒りの恐ろしさっていうのはそういうもので
それ人を殺しちゃう 率先殺しちゃう
他人の幸福を奪う ですから甘えるんじゃなくて
怒りを何とかした方がいいんじゃないかなと
で お釈迦様は法華経でこういう偈文がございまして
パレーチャナ・ヴィジャナーンティ マヤメッタヤマアマセー ケーチャタッタ・ヴィジャナーンティ タトーサッマンティ メーダガーという偈文があります
長いんだからあんまり書きたくはないんだけど
口で言うのは簡単ですけど
[笑い]まあ大体四行目のそれなんですけど
パレチャナウィジャナンティマヤメッタヤママセ
イエチャタッタウィジャナンティタトサンマンティメデガ
法句経にあります そこで言葉一つずつ申し上げると
パレというのはこの人々
他人という意味なんですね
この人々は チャ抜けてナウィジャナンティという言葉がございます
知りません 理解していない
この人々は理解していないんだ
何を理解していないんだと
マヤン 我々はエッタこの場合ヤママセ死んでしまう
破壊してしまうと 我々は破壊してしまうと
我々自身が破壊してしまうと
この連中は知りません
この人々は知りませんと
その怒っている人々に対して言うのです
いわゆる死ぬのは ひどい目に遭うのは私自身だよという事実は知りません
それでイエチャタッタウィジャナンティ
もし誰かがタッタこの問題をウィジャナンティ理解するならば
いわゆる怒りによって自分自身が破壊するということを理解するならば
たとそのことによってメーダガというの争い戦いなんです
サンマンティ なくなってしまう
すべての争いが消えるんだと
いわゆるなぜ世の中に争いがありますかというと
この争う人 その人自身が破壊して死んでしまうという事実はわかっていない
私は相手を倒したとものすごい誤解しているんです
私はあの人によく言ってあげましたと
そういうふうに自慢するでしょうに
でも自分に言われたことだけなんですよ
自分が怒って人に何か言ったら
自分がまず先に不幸になってるんです
自分がものすごい不幸な感じを味わってるんです
自分の心がもう破壊してるんです
ですから 怒りというものは
まず先に自分自身を殺しちゃうんだと
それ分かれば人間っていうのは怒りません
何があろうとも怒りません
どんなひどい条件に遭おうとも
どんなきつい仕事をさせようとも
どんなきつい言葉言おうとも
怒ったらこっちの負けだから
自分が毒飲んだんだから
なんで自分自身で毒を取って飲むんですかね
そういう必要ないんだと
だから怒りを治めるために必要なのは
それを理解することなんです
怒った人は自分を壊しているんだと
それで次のポイントに行きますけど
どのように怒りが生まれるかということを考えましょう
それもう半分は説明してきますけど
それは法句経の偈文ありますから
そこからいきます  法句経
法句経ですね まずこれだけ書いておきます
長いんですから アッコッチマン
この怒る人々はこういうふうに思います
アッコッチマン マンというのは私をということで
アッコッチというのは叱れ叱れ叱れらと思います
まあ私を叱ったと 私を叱ったと
きつい言葉 これはきつい言葉で叱ること
あの人 私を叱ったんではないかと
いわゆるこの人々が私にきつい言葉を言うんじゃないんですかと
それから 次のことアワディマン
あの人々が私をいじめてるんではないか
アワディっていうのはこの痛い
痛める いじめる 怪我するという意味なんです
トーチャリング まあ例えばまあまあ
そういういろんなことで
我々は精神的にも肉体的にも痛めいじめられる時ありますね
他人から それで他人にいじめられたら
痛めつけられたら あ この連中私を痛めつけられた
私をいじめた というふうに思う
同じ行なんですけど アジニマン
一つそれからアハシメ
アジニマンというのは私を負けたというんですか
私に勝ったと ある いろんな人生競争の中で自分が負けたところで
この連中に負けたと この人々は私を負けてしまったというんです
ちょっと文章おかしいかもしれませんけど
この人々が私に勝ってしまったというか
英語で簡単でThey defeated me
あるいはI was defeated by them Defeat
負けたということ この人々は私に勝ってしまった
アハシメっていうのは
自分の持っているものは持っていったということ
私のものを取られたと
あとで説明いたします
イエタン ウパナイハンティ
イエタンウパナイハンティ
ヴェーランテーサンナサンナティ
こういう風な この前の行で言ったように私を叱った
私に迷惑をかけた 私をいじめた
私に勝ってしまった 私のものを奪われたと
イエ誰かが タン そのようにウパナイハンティ
いちいちいちいち頭の中で考える
頭の中で悶々と考えている
悩んだり悔しがったりする
ウパナイハンティっていうのはそういう意味なんです
大体暗い人々はそういうことでしょ
頭の中でいつでも人に負けたあだこだとかね
悔しいとか頭の中で考えてるんです
いろんなことを 頭はもう赤ちゃんのように
なんでもう花見たら泣くは笑うは
お母さんに何か言われたらすぐ泣くは
まあそれで終わっちゃいますから
すごい心の中綺麗で それで終わりますけど
それ大人はそうじゃないんですね
頭の中で覚えて思い出したりして
また延々と回転するんですよ
そういう概念を そういう回転すると
テーサン 彼らのヴェーラン 2番目の言葉
動作ではなくて ヴェーラン
ちょっと強烈な怒りなんですね
ヴェーランナサンナティ
治めることはない 消えることはありません
それは怒りが生まれる原因なんです
これは真剣に理解しないと役に立たないんです
なんかどこかの説法屋というふうな感じで
ちょっと聞き流す感じででは決して幸福を掴めません
ものすごい真剣に心に入れて噛み砕いて理解しないと
仏説は大体私は何でも観説客観的に見てくださいと言うんだけど
釈迦の教えだけは徹底的に主観的に見ると
すぐその場であの幸福感じられます
解脱の道にすぐ入ることができます
でまあ一応説明いたしますが
アッコチマンというのは叱ったという言葉で
世の中で昔も今もこれからもあるんですよ
人間喋っている言葉は
自分が叱られていると
批判していると 私を軽く評価しているんだと
あるいは評価していないんだと
この人は私のことを無視しているんだと
バカにしているんだと
そういうふうに思うんじゃないんですか
人の言葉を聞いて そういうことなんです
そう思うたびに気持ちは幸福ですか？なんか私をバカにしているみたいだと思うと幸福ですかね
気持ち悪いでしょうに
なんか私を完全に無視しているんだと思うと気持ち悪い
私をなんか貶されてるんではないか
軽視しているんではないかと思うと気持ち悪くなる
そういうふうに思う 思っただけではなくて
後でも思う それを覚えておく
勉強するものはすぐ忘れる
私の話でもすぐもう経っちゃうらもう全部忘れてるんです
私もあまり日本語できませんだからいろいろきつい言葉とかね
間違ってる言葉とか言ったりするんだけど
それだけ頭の中全然忘れないように大事に守る
そういう性格ですから
もう人間っていうのは不幸そのものになっているんです
いいことだったら 役に立つことだったら覚えていたっていいんだけど
人はたとえ間違ってても
人のことをちょっと言い過ぎになったとか
ちょっと気が付かないで何か言ったことは気に障ったとか
それで気に障ったならば
それだけは徹底的に覚えている
あんまりにもバカバカらしいんです
それで結果としてどうなるかというと
例えば私はあまりにも楽しくて
その人のことがすごく可愛くて
あんた本当に大バカもんですねと言ったかもしれません
でもちょっと僕みたいな人っていうのは
声がすごく高いんだから
どうせ怒っているように聞こえるんです
普通の人は怒ったら低る声っていうのは
僕の場合は普通なんです
いくらでも声は高くすることはできますけど
低くするのはできない
これは私の問題じゃなくて
これはもう体の筋肉の問題だから
で それでもし私は本当は相手のことを可愛くて
愛情があって バカですよと言ったとしても
その人に気に障ったというと
その人はそれを覚えておいて
さらにさらに自分でそれを思い出したりする
頭の中で回転させたりする
妄想したりする 思考を働かす
それで考えれば考えるほど
どんどん怒りの感情が生まれてくる
自分の幸福が消えていく
自分の体が壊していく
それで悪口を言ったのは私かもしれませんだけど
その人は自分の家族やら仕事の仲間やら
みんなの幸福を奪ってしまって
ひどい目に遭っちゃうし
他人もひどい目に遭わせてしまう
それはアッコチマンということで
アワビマンというのはもう体に痛めつけることですけど
それもあることはあるし
まあね 学校で肉体的なイジメとかありますけど
でも大人になってもイジメは消えてないんですね
大人になっても互いにイジメたりする
それは男性だけじゃないんですよ
女性もよくやるんです
とにかくイジメる 他人をいろんなことで
そういうふうなことでイジメられてると
それを覚えてる 絶対忘れない
忘れないで覚えておくんだったら
まあ勝手にどうぞ あなたは不幸になるよということしか言えませんよ
あの人 私をいじめたと
ほんのわずかなことでも
そういうふうに思うようになると
怒りが生まれてくる アジニマンというのは私に勝ってしまったということで
だからそれは世の中でいつでもあるでしょうに
競争の世界だから 誰かが勝って誰かが負けるんですよ
商売の世界ででも自分だけ儲かるだけという世界はあるわけじゃないんです
儲かったりするは 損したりはするは
試験の場合でも まあそれはまあ選択とか選べる試験だったらみんな選べるわけじゃないし
落ちる人々もいるし ですから
我々は常にこの負けることを味わわなくちゃいけないんです
それ嫌だと思ったら生きていられませんだから
世の中っていうのは 生命っていうのは競争の論理で成り立っているんだから
競争の過程で確実に誰かがそれは成功すると
誰かが負けなくちゃいけないんです
たとえ幼稚園にしたっても
20メートル走り競争にしたっても
1番目になる人もいて
ビリになる人もいるんです
それは避けられない現実でしょうに
それで愚かな人々があいつは勝ったんだと
どうでもいいことで関係ないことだから
その人 勝ったのはその人の才能であって
能力であって 自分にそういう才能能力なかったんだから負けたんであって
それはどうしようもないことでしょうに
あの人さえなければ いなければ
私はその仕事をもらうのにとか
この学生とこの学生といなかったならば
私は合格するのにとか
そういうふうに思ったりする
例えば 女性 2人が一人の男性と仲良くしているんだと
それでその男性が二人とも結婚できませんだから一人選んじゃうと
もう選ばれないと ものすごい憎しみ
痛み 苦しみ 強烈な怒りとか感じたりする場合も実際にありますから
で 私もたまにそういうことを僕も聞く場合がありますけど
あの女は本当にずるいんだと
いろいろずるいことをして
あの男を捕まえたと 本当は私の方がもっとその人のことを心配しているんだと
ああだこうだとか あれ私はあまりこのもう何て言いますか
あまりおしゃれしたりとかね
そういうふうに人を騙そうとしなかったんです
でも あの女の人はもう毎日いっぱいおしゃれしたりして
見せかけをして あの男を騙したとか
結局自分の怒りでしょうね
その場合でも競争でしたから
一人が勝った 一人が負けた
それだけのこと それ避けられないことなんです
そこで我々っていうのは競争しよう
競争しようと言いながらも
負けて悔しいと 負けてなんで悔しいからな
競争するんだから 勝ちも負けもどっちも同じことで
どっちでもそのまま受け入れればいいし
そうはしない それで怒りが暴挙する
あはすめってのは私を盗んだということで
それをよくまたそれで世の中でありますね
騙されてお金取られたとかに
あるいはずるいことをして
あの会社は落札する あの会社もあれ取ったんだと
裏でお金払ったんだとかね
それで私たちはもう負けたんだとか
そういうふうに損得のことでまた怒ると
問題は頭の中でそれを覚えてることなんです
それでどんどん怒りが成長する
どんどん無礼なになってしまっちゃいます
あと 自分を破壊する 他人を破壊する前に
不幸味わう ですから たとえわずかでも
我々の頭の中でこのくだらない妄想概念をやめると
そうすると怒りが消えてしまう
で また話したのはほんのわずかで
まだたくさんありますけど
じゃあもう時間もなくなったんだけど
最後のポイントに行きます
怒りは収める方法 どうすれば怒りが生まれないように我々に生活できるかと
で まずこの経典のことを言う前に
大事なポイントを一つ言いたい
怒るのは臆病者なんです
あまりにも臆病者で 弱くて
自信がなくて そういう人は怒るんです
偉そうに 自分には全く自信がない
社会に堂々と胸張って生きていられない
何でも怖がっちゃう いわゆる腰抜けというか
間抜けというか そんな性格の人々なんで全部怒るの
あれかっこつけるんですよ
みんなに怖い顔を見せたりして
すごくなんかみんな近寄りがたいような
ものすごく偉そうにカッコつけてるだけ
何も中身はないんです
たとえ会社の偉い人であろうとも
ザンザン部下を叱ったりとか
みんなにもうものすごい怒鳴ったりするでしょ
あれは全く中身ない空っぽな人で
決してリーダーではないんです
何の人格もない ものすごい頭が悪い
だから怒るんです だから怒る人は性格的にはもう人間の中ではもう最低なんです
何もできない 負け犬なんです
だからまず覚えてください
私たちは怒るんだったらもう負け犬
もう何にももう絶対的なそれなんです
勝てない 動物の世界ですっききちんと見える
弱い動物はすぐ怒るんです
堂々たる動物はもう全然怒りません
で 人間に向かってでもよく攻撃する動物とかね
我々に邪魔をする動物は結構小さいでしょうに
例えば森の中でゾウという一番大きい動物はいるんですよ
誰にも迷惑をかけない
堂々たる姿で 王様のように
あっち行ってこっち行って
枝をちょっと切って食べて
草葉っぱちょっと取って食べて
それで草なんか葉っぱ取るでしょ
ゾウさんが取ってこうやってきちんと拭くんです
あれは 何て言いますか
こうすごい力強く ゾウね
ものすごい力ありますから
力強く強くあれ振っちゃうと
土やらこの虫やら全部落ちるんです
きれいになるんです それぐらいもう立派な生活しています
そこで虎が水飲む時は鹿はもう来ない
隠れています 象さんが水飲もうと思って湖に入ると
虎がいようがライオンがいようが
鹿がいようがもう関係ない
その連中もそこら辺そこら辺で水を飲んだり遊んだりする
全くもう なぜならば象というのはものすごい力強い
動物の中で言うことを全然聞かないのはサイですか
インドでもこのサイの面倒を見る場合は近寄れないんです
そこで象に乗っていくんです
象に乗っても寝ている際の側にも行くんです
別に象はサイを踏んだりするわけでもないんだけど
サイが象を見ると やっぱりこいつこいつに踏まれたら危ないんだからよけましょうと自分がよけるだけ
麻酔でも打たなくちゃいけない時は
検査のためにちゃんと象に乗っていて
サイのそばに行って打つんです
ですから 本当に力強い人は怒りません
本当のリーダーは怒りません
いわゆる真の人間は怒りません
偽物だけ だから怒りを収める方法で
まずそれを覚えてください
真のリーダーになること
真の人間の真の人間になること
真の王様になること 皇帝になること
皇帝になったら別に怒る必要ないんだから
だから怒らない心を持つ人こそ人間のリーダーであって
本当の中身からもその人々はリーダーなんです
ですから 我々の社会の中で
たとえ誰であろうが 負け犬だったらさんざん怒る
でも 社会システムの中でいろいろありますから
我々ちょっと面倒くさいことは
例えば子供が生まれた
でも母親は負けの一人
犬と言っても それを女性名詞にしてみてください
日本語であるかどうかわかりませんだけど
で そうすると母親には子供の面倒を見られない
自信がない それどうなるかというと
子供は泣くと母親が怒る
そこで強引に自分に言い聞かせちゃうんですよ
怒ってはいけない 子供はなんとか泣き覚まなくちゃいけないと
いろいろ子供は自分の子供なら可愛いんだとか思ってやっちゃいますけど
うまくいかない それでストレス溜まる
神経質になる それでものすごいすごくヒステリーになる
で 最終的にはものすごくなんとか虐殺するようになんてますか
幼児虐殺 たまに自分の子供を殺そうとまでするんです
別に愛情がないわけじゃないんです
完全に病気になってしまうんです
ですから 最初から負け犬なんですよ
自信ある母親が 子供はいくら夜泣きしたっても
まあなんとかして まあそれはもうコントロールする
怒りはしない 子供に怒っても
これは何やってるんですかと
きちんと命令もできる
でも心の中で全然怒ってない
だから心の中で怒ってない場合は
その母親にはきちんと子供を育てられます
怒ってないっていうのは
なんだかんだいいですよ
いいですよっていうのは
そういう弱音じゃないんです
それはある人々は誤解して
子供は目の前で悪いことしてるんです
怒ってはいけないと 私
スマナサーラにも聞けましたから
ということで もう見ていたんです
弱いことして悪いことしているのに
はいはいわかりましたと
で 自分は腰上げる それ見たら
私はこれはアカンと そんなことで何にもなれないんだと
子供に対して本当に愛情があるんだったら
あんたそんなことやるのはいけませんよと言えるでしょうに
そんなことするのはもうお母さん嫌いですよと
いけません そういうことは
かっこ悪いんだと と言えないんですね
あれは正しい道じゃないんです
本当の愛情あると王様のような感じで生きていられるんです
怒りさえなければ それは悪い
やめなさいと それだけで終わるんです
そこで聞いてくれないということは
自分の心の中に愛情がない
自信がない だから言うは言うは言うは何回何回繰り返して同じことを何回も言うと
そうすると向こう側は聞かない
会社にしたって同じことで
それはいけません だからやめなさいときちんと言ったら
向こう側きちんと聞いてくれると
この人には自信があるということで
よく見られるんですから
この自信がなくと 世の中むちゃくちゃになっていて
むちゃくちゃになってさらに怒ると
何でもうまくいかない
それは怒りがものすごく自分の人格そのものになってしまっているんだから
ですから 怒るのは愚か者だと
怒るのは知恵も知識もないんだから
理解能力ないんだから
もしどなたかが怒りの問題で悩んでいるならば
私は別に何も言いませんだけど
そういうことだと自分に言い聞かせてください
全く知識も能力も才能も何もないんだと
だから自分がカンカン何だかんでも怒るんだと
そういうことで まあそれから経典から申し上げると
で 怒りというのは抑えてなくすもんじゃないんです
怒りを抑えます 我慢しますとか
それで消えるんじゃないんです
なぜならば そもそも愚か者だから怒ってるんだから
我慢しますと 歯を噛んで舌を噛んで我慢したって
怒りは怒りだから 生まれた毒はそこにあるんだから
どこまで我慢するんですかね
そのバカどもが 社会で生きている時は怒るでしょうに
怒ったら我慢するんだと
死ぬまで我慢しなきゃいけないんでしょうに
それできないんです 何か正しい方法あるはずなんです
それでどうせ正しく教えてないと我々言うんだけど
ヨーロッパの考え方は発散しろと
ストレスは それほど危ないことはこの世の中でないんです
それは怒りやら感情は正当化していることなんです
発散すればあなた正常するんだと
また起こったらまた発散するんだと
怒りの発散というのは発散ですか
言葉はまあ決していいことじゃないんです
それまた迷惑だから 世の中に
それは例えば私の足がちょっと怪我して痛いんだと
僕は悩んでいる それで人が来て
あなた足が怪我して悩んでるでしょ
じゃあ私はその痛みを感じないようにしてあげますと
はい 分かります お願いしますと言ったところで
野球バットで持ってきて私の足にぶん殴っちゃうと膝に
で 膝折れると 言ったらあの痛みでもう宇宙は全部星が見えてしまったと
それで足の怪我の痛みなんかはないでしょう
それ本人が言ったこと正しいんです
そこで殴られたことで
まだあの怪我痛いんですか？と
それは痛くないんです
もうこの発散の原理はそういう原理なんです
そうじゃなくて 毒を抜くことしかないんです
だからこの サティ実践でヴィパッサナー実践というか
このサティを実践することこそ
世の中で科学的な方法はありません
ですから 怒りが生まれるとすぐ自分を見てください
怒りだ 怒りだ これは怒りの感情だと
怒りそのものの勉強をしてください
今の瞬間に これは怒りだ
今は気持ちは悪い 今私は幸福の感じではありませんと
私という言葉入れませんだけどね
これは怒りです これは怒りの感情だ
今起こっているんだと
外に向いてる自分の目を内に向いてあげてください
内に向くようにしてください
人が何か言うとすぐ損地に怒ってしまう
そこまではしょうがないと
怒った瞬間で人の言葉を延々と聞くんじゃなくて
これは怒りだ 怒りだと見てください
そうすると怒りが生まれたその瞬間で消えてしまう
その瞬間で消えてしまう
その瞬間で消えてしまったら
心は次の瞬間感じようとする
怒りが消えたらすごく気持ちいいんです
例えばすごく頭が痛い時
バファリンでも飲んだらそれ消えちゃうでしょ
消えたらすごい気持ちよくて元気なんです
そういう風に怒り見た瞬間で怒りが消える
その時はすごく心が元気になる
元気になった瞬間で幸福を感じる
幸福を感じたら自信がついてきます
自分を褒められる あ 怒りが消えちゃった
我ながら結構自己コントロールできるんだと
あ それだったら何のことない
人の話を聞いていられるんです
全然怒りの感情なしに
ですからそこ それですね
この方法っていうのは
怒り収める方法っていう
すぐ自分の心を見る 心を見ることで消えるんです
いろんなことをやらなくてもいいんです
簡単で それで今度瞬時にできるんです
それ怒りがない人 怒りではなくてサティというか
今の自分に気づき気づいてない人っていうのは
まあ仏教の言葉っていうのは愚か者という言葉で死んでる人々で
寝ている人々で 酔ってる人々という言葉で考えているんです
だからその瞬間に怒りに気づかなかった怒りの感情を持っていた人は
後でそれを思い出したりする
もう話終わっているのに
1日 2日 3日  1ヶ月とか 1年
3年経っても覚えている
覚えてて思い出して思い出して怒る
怒るたびに自己破壊する
そこは 1番目として覚えて 1番と一番大事な方法っていうのはそれだけなんです
それでも効かないんだったら
お釈迦様の例えがあります
それででも使ってくださいと
もっとみたいなもの で
それはみんなに合わないかもしれませんだけど
自分たちが本当に正直者かないかということは必要なんですよ
あんまり正直な人間っていうのは
なかなか世の中で見当たりませんだけどね
まあ自分が正直者だと自分で思うならば
次の 2番目の方法はできるんです
どういうことかというと
お釈迦様はこう言うんです
例えば 恐ろしい泥棒たちが来て
何も悪いことをしていない自分を捕まって
のこぎりで自分を切ると
別に何のこともしてないんだけど
あ こいつを切ってみましょうと
面白いよと ただそれだけのことで
捕まってのこぎりで自分を切ると
その時でもわずかでも嫌だとかね
わずかでも怒るなと それぐらい恐ろしい人についても
わずかにでも怒ったら
あんた方は仏教の人々ではありませんと
ブッダの教えを信仰するし
実践する連中ではありませんと
お釈迦様はそういう人々はもう弟子破門
ですから まあ仏教仏弟子になりたければ
それぐらいの覚悟ですか
生きててほしいと それで
正直でないと実践できませんだけどね
それを覚えておいて 決して我々はそういう目には遭わないかもしれません
たとえ人々に殺されようしたとも
泥棒入ったところで 自分を泥棒殴ろうとしたところで殺されるかもしれませんし
そういうことはそんなにあるわけじゃないでしょうに
そういうことになっても怒り怒ったらもうお釈迦様から破門だよと
お釈迦様はそれぐらい怒り怒るのはいけませんと
それぐらい毒ですよと
殺される瞬間で怒っても
殺される人は損するんだと
心が恐ろしく汚れたんだから
もう死ぬでしょうに 死ぬ瞬間に怒って死んじゃったらもう地獄に行くんだから
今まで得た徳は全部もう無効になってしまっちゃいますし
ですから怒らないというふうなことを決めると
世の中で何かちょっと言われたんだとかね
自分を無視したんだとかね
姑さんにちょっと何かいじめられたとかね
失礼なこと言われたとか
そんなもんで怒られますかね
そんなくだらないつまらないことで
ですから やっぱり怒れないのはすごい人なんですよ
すごい人格ある 私は殺されても
私はその殺す側に対しては怒りは持てないんだと
それぐらい覚悟があれば
世の中に生きるということは何のこともないんですよ
普段も誰かちょっとした一言葉言うとかね
ちょっと気に障る一言葉言う
それぐらいのことだから
会社でもいじめたい場合はもう大事な仕事はもう任せてくれないとかね
あるいは一番つまらない仕事に
まあどうでもやってもやらなくてもどうでもいい仕事に出すとかね
何の言ったって仕事ないとかね
それにより自分の人生破壊する必要ありますかと
自分の明るさだけ消さないように守ると
そういう問題はすぐその場で解決しますよ
例えばもう今あるかどうかわかりませんけど
前あったんですね この会社の人をクビにしたくて
もう仕事はない ただもう余計なプライドあるんだから
会社に行ってまあ座ってるだけ
それですっごく気持ち悪くて
もし私にそういうことをされたなら
私はどうしますかというと
新聞やら冊子やら 読みたい本やら
全部片っ端から会社に持っていく
持ってて足も机の上に入れて
こうやって読んだりする
何も事はなく コーヒー入れるわ
紅茶入れるわ みんなにも配るわと
でお菓子で持ってきて食べながら本を読んだりとか
もう会社帰る時間になったらもう帰ると
これを日 2日やるともう全部解決しますから
で 自分も楽しいし また負けではないし
あの状態は堂々と受けてる仕事ないんだから
私はその時間を思いっきり使いますよと
それで向こう側がもっとそれに怒って
あんたよくも本読んだりする
だってどうすればいいんですかね
私はもうやることないんだから元気でいますよとか
あんた方しっかり仕事しなさいと
喋るんじゃないよと 仕事あるんじゃないかと
と言ったら それで勝ちですよ
こちらの そこじゃなくて
余計な見栄やら自我やらいろんなものあったりして
これは会社のいじめだとか
私を何とかしてクビにしたいんだとか
自分で仕事を辞めてほしくてとかとか
会社は自分をクビにしたら会社お金払わなくちゃいけないんだから
そういうことを考えたり考えて悩んだり悩んだり
結局そうなるでしょうに
それはかわいそう ですから
大体生きている社会であるこのいじめというのは
そんな通ったことない
それ通ったことないと思うたびに
ためにはお釈迦様のこのモットー覚えておいてください
たとえ私は泥棒かけて鋸で切ってバラバラに切っても
私は怒りませんと 怒ったら私の負けだと
まあ大体それぐらいのことで怒りっていうのはなくなりますよね
で 次に言えるのは このなぜ怒るか
この自我なんでエゴなんですよ
私 俺という概念 これすごい邪魔なもんなんですよ
自我を捨てて行動すれば何のこともないんです
私はこれやらなくちゃいかない
私は偉い人だと 私を認めてくれなくちゃいけないんだと
なんで自分にそういうふうにくだらない評価するんですかね
私は男だよと思ったら
また女性を差別しようとする
私は女性だと思ったところに
また男性を馬鹿にしようとする
私はよく勉強して よく立派な大学出ているんだと思っちゃったら
他の人を馬鹿にしようとする
結局馬鹿見るのは誰ですかね
そう思う人でしょうね
だから東大は卒業したんだけど
それから人生は不幸だらけとか
人を馬鹿にしようとするんだから
人いう他のことを聞こうとしないんだから
会社でうまくいかないわ
人間関係うまくいかないわ
一人ぼっちになるわ それすると体心が暗くなっちゃって
もう能力がなくなってしまう
不幸だらけで ですから
なんで自分を評価 そういうふうなくだらない評価するんですかね
それはエゴなんですよ
私は何者でもないんだと
と思ってしまえば 例えば東大卒業した人であろうとも
誰かがあんたこの部屋を掃除しなさいと言ったら
掃除しなさいと言われた
じゃあ掃除します それだけのことでしょうに
東大卒業人が会社に入ったところで
部屋の掃除と言われたら
これ大変な問題になるんです
例えば女性の場合はお茶入れなさいとか言われるんだそうで
それで女性たちがずいぶん悩んでるんです
かなり悩んで もう体が壊しちゃって
病気になったりして もう見ていられないんですよ
ただのお茶入れなさいということだけで
そんなにも悩んだり 苦しがったり
怒って自分の健康まで壊す
どれまでバカですかと
お茶入れるとお茶入れればいいんだから
別にどうって会社に行ったらもう終わるまで会社にいるんだから
お茶入れようが便所の掃除しようが関係ないでしょうに
時間決まってるし その時間にできる仕事は決まってるし
ですから 自然の流れの中で別に何のことのないで
例えば 1 日できない仕事
例えば何かコピーしなさいと
これは 1万部コピーしなさいと
コピーして ちゃんとそれ止めてファイル作ってみんなに配りなさいとと言ったって
それ 1 日でできないでしょうに
それから自分がそれでずっとやればいい
それでお茶入れなさいと言ったら怒るでしょ
こんなに仕事あるのに
お茶入れなさい これやっちゃったら
なんのかい分かりますと
お茶入れればいい それには 30 分かかったならば
別に会社には文句言えませんだから
30 分のこちらの仕事ができなくなった
それは向こうのせいだから
自分が怒る必要ないんです
なぜ怒るかというと 余計なプライド
エゴ それ捨てれば 私は社長だ
私は部長だとか 私は奥さんだ
私は旦那だとか 例えば結婚したら私は旦那ではなくと思ったら
ものすごい亭主関白で子供をいじめるは
子供を奥さんをいじめるは
もう家庭は不幸にするは
あんまりにもバカバカらしいんです
ですから これは言いたくないほどなんですよ
ですから 向こうはこの一つだけ
2つだけだけ言いたいだけなら
今日はサティで確認しろということと
2番目にこのお釈迦様のあのたとえを覚えておきましょう
それだけで十分ですけど
こんなことはね あんまり言いたくないほどバカバカらしいんですよ
人間 エゴを持っていて
肩書きを持っていて それは自分の足かせになってしまうんです
自分十字架を背負うようになっちゃうんです
エゴっていうのは自分が背負っている十字架みたいなもんなんです
十字架は何のために運んでいくんです？殺していただくためなんです
だからエゴを持ってプライドを作ってください
そこに怒りそのもので自己破壊になります
それは自分が背負う十字架になるんです
十字架 あの イエス様のストーリー知ってますね
イエス様 あの 何といいますか
殺すことを決めちゃって
このもうこの人を殺すべきですよ
言ったら それはまあ 向こう側が殺したければ
向こう側はちゃんと十字架を負いでそこに釘を打った方がいいのに
その十字架 イエス様が運んでいかなくちゃいけない
そこでも言われているのは
やっぱり 自分がエゴを持ったならば
それは自分の十字架になる
だからエゴを持って生きている人々は
同時に限りない苦しみを持っていくんです
社会と何の調和もなく
社会と逆らって持っていくんです
ですから  3番目に言えるのは
エゴを捨てましょうと
名前ぐらいはいいんですよ
それ以上何もいりません
例えばエゴを捨てたところで
田中さんと言ったっても
全然聞こうとしないと
もう体もそうやってあなたのことだと
私は田中でしたっけ？私はエゴがないんだから忘れたんだと
そこまではなくてもいいんですけど
まあ自分の名前ぐらいは
これはまあこの人の人やと
それ以上何も持たないことを決めてください
私はあなたはどなたですか？で
田中ですと それだけで結構です
私は何々 こういうこういうことで
こういうこういう者だよと言っちゃったら
もうその人はものすごい苦しみを背負っている人なんです
ですから 例えば 40歳
45歳ぐらいの人が若者入っているコンビニとかなんかにバイトに行ったら
もうなかなか居心地が悪いと
ありますでしょうに 今いい仕事があっても
自分の会社を辞められませんし
なぜならば 今仕事をしている会社では年取ってるんだから立場があって
新しい会社に入っちゃったら
入ったばっかしだから立場がないと
それで自分より目上の人と年下であると
それでもなかなかうまくいかないという
これは日本だけの現象ですけど
それで困ったりする それで人間の自由はなくなってるんです
いい仕事 面白い仕事あるのに行けない
そこで雇ってくれない
あんた今 45 だから こちらの例えば面接する人
もしかすると 30歳かもしれません
それで私は若者やとエゴを持っている
面接受ける側が私は結構仕事をしている熟年者だってエゴを持っている
そうすると自分でやりたいも給料もいい面白い仕事はあるのに
それできない それでエゴがなしにあんたはどういう経験がありますか？とかね
どういう仕事できます？それなりに面接OKですよと
エゴない場合は自分の上司がいくら年下の人であろうとも関係なくなっちゃうんです
何のことなくすごく気楽に仕事できる
それ あの すごくエゴなんです
だから名前だけに十分だと
名前だけにしますと決めれば
そこでまた全ての苦しみはさっと消えているはずなんです
で もう時間なんですけど
で もう一つポイントなんですけど
人々が自分がいくら落ち着いていても
怒ることをするかもしれません
その時はもっと冷静に物事を見る能力を持って
客観的に物事を見る この人
まあ部長だから まあ部長の立場で喋ってるんだと
私も部長になったらおそらくそうなるだろうと
どうせ我々は仕事を失敗ばっかりで
だからその人も被害者であると
私をいじめているのではなくて
私をいじめているその人も被害者ですよ
例えば姑さんが嫁さんをいじめると
姑さんはもう被害者ですよと
息子を奪われて 一人ぼっちになって
自分が今まで全部支配していたのに
支配していた女王様がもう追い出されて
外から来ている人が全部権力を取っているんだと
だからその状況を理解して
被害者ですよと 理解しておけば
すぐそこに解決というものが出てくる
ですからみんなそういうもので
被害者だよと思うことも一つの方法
それからもう一つ 人が怒っていろんなことをする
私たちをいじめようとしている
その場合は怒るんではなくて
その人の心を見る その人には自信がない
この人は不安で だから私をいじめようとしている
けなそうとしている 無視しようとしている
私の能力を馬鹿にしようとしている
私の能力を馬鹿にしているのは
その人に能力がないんだから
ですからその人はかわいそうで
被害者で その人は自分の怒りを表しているだけですよと
大体怒っている人は怒ってたまらなくて
これ毒だから 何とかしてそれは消さなくちゃいけない
だから体にエネルギー溜まったら
我々それを消すために走る
仕事をする 喋る いろんなことをしますでしょうに
子供にご飯食べさせたらどうしますかね
もうめちゃくちゃもう遊び回るでしょうに
溜まったエネルギーをなくしてしまうまで
それなくなっちゃったら何のことなく平気で寝ちゃうと
そういう感じで人間っていうのは自分の心に怒りの毒が生まれたら
それを出さなくちゃいけない
そのエネルギーを そのために喋っているんであって
私には関係ありませんと
例えば能力ない上司が能力いっぱいある部下にいろんなけなす言葉を言うんだと
そうするとけなされている部下が
それ私に関係はございませんと
心の中で この人にはいろいろ能力はないし
歳も取っているし ですから自分のことを心配して
自分のことで悩んで そのストレスを発散しているんだと
ですからまあそこら辺は一応助けてあげましょうと
ということで その人の話を聞いていると
聞いて受け入れることは要りません
私が今言っているこの大事なポイントなんかを受け入れてもいいんだけど
それは受け入れませんしね
余計なゴミは受け入れますし
ですからそれは余計なゴミだから
その人は自分の体に溜まったゴミを外に出していますから
なんで自分がゴミ箱にならなくちゃいけないんですかね
ですから いじめる相手が
叱る相手が 自分の体に溜まっている毒を出しているだけであって
出させるようにしてあげましょうと
綺麗になるまで 落ち着くまで
私はあの人が吐いているものをまだ食べて自分もお腹を壊す必要はないんだと
その人は何かひどいものを食べてお腹を壊しちゃって
今吐いている状態で それを我々行ってまた取って食べる
拾って食べるんだから
そういうふうに覚えてください
人がやること言うことは
その人々が何かお腹が壊す
ものすごいひどいものを食べたんだと
食べてそれを今吐いている状態ですから
吐いたものだから 私はそれをまた拾って食べる必要はないんだと
それすごい汚いでしょうに
美味しいものを食べて吐いたっても食べられますか
それは拾って 今みんなそうやっているんです
そこで怒ったりする人々が
怒ったり人をおこらせをしている人々が
食べてはいけないものを食べて
体に悪いものを食べたところで
それ吐いているんだからさらに汚いんです
それ拾って食べませんと
ですから 世の中から怒る原因が生まれたら
それは吐いたものとして見てください
それを受け入れてはいけないんです
その状態に心を育てると
もう何のことなく怒りがすぐ即座に消える
それであの孫は迷ったんですね
この怒るのはもう間抜けだと
あまりも頭が悪いんだと
能力も知識も何もないんだと
ということを言ったんだけど
エゴを捨てればその問題もないんです
私には能力がないんだと思うと
エゴだから それも この人はいろいろ能力があって元気で
もう悔しいと思ったら
いじめの気持ちが出てくる
エゴを捨てちゃえばその問題もないで
能力がなくて何が悪いんですかと
能力ある人がすればいいんだから
絵は描けない人は絵を描けなくてもよろしいし
描ける人は描いたらいいんです
ピアノを弾けない人がなんでピアノを弾ける人に対して怒るんですかね？悔しがるんですかね？いじめるしてるんですかね？だから私たちから見れば
お願いだからあなたはピアノを弾かないでくださいと
弾けない人は聴いていればいいんだから
ですから 自分に能力がないんだ
ああだこうだとか そういうことはもう嫌い
人を馬鹿にしようとしている
だから間抜けであって
自信がなくても けしからん人間であることは確かなんですけど
それもエゴだから汚いんであって
エゴさえなくなったら別に何のこともないんです
ピアノを弾ける人がいるんだったら
聴く 聴いてくれる人も必要でしょうに
そうするとその問題も消えてしまう
そういうこと まあそれからあまり意味がないんだけど
例えば理解する  understanding
そこは重要なポイントなんですね
これはあんまり厳密に頭使って何かやってる知識的な行動ではなくて
このその状況はその背景の中で把握して理解するということなんです
それは落ち着きから出てくるんです
なんとなく心の中に自然に生まれてくる静けさみたいなものなんです
understanding というのは
例を言うとわかるかもしれません
例えば子供は学校に行きたくないんですよと言ったら
我々はすぐ怒ってしまう
大変だと なんで学校に？学校に行きなさいと
それ怒りなんです 学校に行きたくないや
行きなさいという反応ではなくて
そこに落ち着き 静けさがあって
学校に行きたくないんだと
学校に行きたくないと
その瞬間だけ ちょっと understanding
この子は学校に行きた
それだけなんです いわゆるその子の心の中に学校に行きたくないという何かことがあるんだと
それわからなくて くだらない妄想概念で学校行けなかったら大変だとか
勉強できなかったら大変だとか
自分が隣のお母さんに何言えばいいんですか？とか
隣のおくさんの子供はちゃんと学校に行ってるのにとか
そこをそういうことを考えてるんです
結局自分のこと 学校に行けと
奴隷じゃないんだから
その場合は あ そうと あなたは
この子は学校に行きたくないと
行きたくないという何かあるんだと
それわかった瞬間 なんとなく落ち着きが出てくる
顔から大変だという何にも出てこない
顔のニコニコは消えません
次に聞けるんですよ 何か訳でもありますか？とかね
学校に行けない何かありますか？とかね
それは私にできることはありますか？とかね
私には何もできなくたっても
お母さんに言ってみたらとかね
で仲良くなって その人と一緒の心の波動を作って
で聞いてみられる その聞いてる途中でもすぐ自分が母に戻ったらダメなんです
落ち着き必要なんです
understanding
そこで母に戻るんじゃなくて
まあ聞いてみて それ理解すれば
それからまあなんとか方法あるでしょうね
問題が分かったら ですから
人が怒って何か言った瞬間に
うちに入った人がすっごく怒って入った瞬間で怒るんじゃなくて
あ 今日はちょっと機嫌が悪いみたいと
落ち着きがあったら それは聞いてみることはできるんです
そういうふうな このちょっとしたアンダースタンディング
ちょっとした心の落ち着き
あればそれも一つの方法になります
それでこの 例えば自分が何か失敗して自分が叱られるようになっちゃうと
あ 嫌だという感じではなくて
こういう失敗がありまして
それでその人はこういうふうに喋っているんだと
本当は失敗はこれぐらいだから
こうこうすればいいんだけど
この喋り方はちょっと余計かも
余計でしょうとかね そういうふうに客観的に見ているんです
その客観的に状況を把握できる静けさ
心の落ち着き それをアンダースタンディングということで
それもすぐ育てられるものなんです
ヒステリーだったらできない
感情的にすぐなるんだったら
それもできない 例えばたまに
例えば仕事の世界でもね
なんか自分が点数取りたくて
実績出したくて 人に仕事も与えないで
もう情報も与えないで
もう自分だけでもういろんな仕事をやったりしていると
それで会社の状況がどんどん悪くなったりすると
それですぐ怒っちゃうでしょうね
勝手に仕事をして それで困るんだと
ちゃんと報告もしないでとかね
その時のちょっとしたアンダースタンディングがあれば
その問題解決します この人は一生懸命自分の実績を出したいと
あるいはただのこの人の見栄だと
あるいはこの人の本当はこの仕事できない
ですから 会社に報告したところで
能力ある人に仕事を任せちゃうんだと
ですから その人は誰にも報告しないで自分だけでやろうとしているんだと
ということをわかる そうすると答えも出てくる
まあ放っておきましょう
放っておく場合も放っておきましょう
でも放っておいたところで会社は大変だったら
まあそれはまあ放っておけないんだから
じゃあそうじゃなくて
我々はこういう仕事をしますから
あんたは他のことをしてくださいと
と言えるし そういうことにはアンダースタンディングということが必要なんです
次には あまり実行できませんかもしれませんが
すべての生命は平等であります
生命として 一切の生命は平等であります
みんなに権利平等なんです
この体形によって仕事が変わっているだけ
ゴキブリは台所に隠れている
それはゴキブリの体によりますから
人間は隠れないで堂々と生活している
うちで飼っている猫はちゃんと餌をもらって食べている
うちに隠れてネズミはみんな寝たところで来て
残り物は食べると それぐらいの差であって
生命としてはみんな同じなんです
ですから 私たちは他人に対して怒る権利は全くない
人に怒る場合は それはもう平等ということはわかってない
みんな平等であって みんなにそれなりの苦しみ
悩みがありまして その人間の苦しみ
生命の苦しみ 互いにぶつかり合っちゃったらもう生きていられないんだと
ですから 私の悩みは私の悩みで
向こうの悩みは向こうの悩みで
そういうふうに平等の気持ちを持ってくると
自我もどんどん消えてしまうし
怒ることはできなくなります
たとえ自分の子供に怒る時でも平等と思ってないんです
だから怒るんです 我々の場合でも
我々の弟子たちに怒る場合は
弟子だからといって怒ったっても
それは良くないんです
弟子といってもそれはまた人の人間だから
そんな勝手に怒る権利はないんです
ですから やっぱり平等であることを理解すれば
学校の先生も生徒たちも平等であって
教頭も平等であって 他人に互いに怒る権利はないんだと
目上の人を怒っちゃうと
前の方法でこの人は自分消化した
食べたものがあるんだから吐いてるんだと
それはまあちょっと放っておいて
放っておいてあげましょうと
自分が自分の下の人々については怒るんじゃなくて
みんな同じですから そんなカンカン怒るんじゃなくて
互いに話し合って問題解決しましょうという状況と平等という概念使えば
それも素晴らしいことと
またいっぱいありますけど
まだ今続けて もう一つだけ言ってやめましょう
たくさんあります とにかく
怒り抑える方法 で 怒ったら自分が負ける
知恵がない 怒らないで
その瞬間で怒らないで
この問題どう解決するべきかと
解決しようとすると なんかすごい刺激が生まれてくるわけです
勝ちましたと それも自分に勝ったことで
知恵が生まれたことで
で ある人はこれはこうです
こうです ある人はいいえ
そうではない ああではないとかね
3番目の人はもう決めなくちゃいけないと
それでこの人は正しい
この人は間違っていると決めちゃったら
もうこれは正しくない
そうじゃなくて その問題を見て
この場合はこういう答えでいいんじゃないかなと
そういう風に知恵を使って解決する方法すると
相手の怒りも収まります
私は個人的には結構その方法を使うんです
いろんな人の問題やらね
いろんなことをしなくちゃいけない時も出てきますけど
だいたい 1年分の仕事でも
まあ 1日でも 1時間  1時間以内では解決してしまうんです
それはもう自分が人の怒りにはもう引かれない
人を言うことももう丸のみしない
うのみしない で こんなことを言うんだから良くない人間やと全然思わない
その人はこういう感情で喋っている
この人はこういう感情で喋っている
実際は問題はこういう問題であると
ですから こういう答えでいかがでしょうかと思って言うと
みんな何のことなく受け入れる
何も議論なしと たまに試しにやると
この延々と議論しようと来るんです
で 喋る時も私は感情で喋らせない人々に
これはいけません こんなことやったら困ります
ちょっと待ってくださいとか
そうじゃなくて 何が問題ですかと
なぜ問題ですかと ポイントだけおっしゃってくださいと
言うと もうそんなたくさん喋れなくなっちゃうんです
相手の心が整理する 自然に
整理したところで問題は整理して出てくるんですね
それにもうちゃんと そういう場合はこういうことではないかなと言ったら
向こうは ああそうだ 自分の答えとして受け取れちゃう
それでこちらの知恵が働いたんだから
自分としてはうまくいきましたと
何時間も議論するところで
もう何も議論なしに問題はありましたと
で 私は最終的にまた何か言いたいことはありますか？と聞くと
大丈夫だよ 何もないんだと
みんなすごく仲良く終わってしまうんです
ですから それは皆様に分かりやすく言う場合は
怒りに勝つこと 負けるんじゃなくて
怒りを乗り越えることはすごい面白いんだと
ものすごい面白いんだと
ものすごい自信と自信ついてくるんだと
覚えておけば まあいいかもしれません
負けるんじゃないんだと
怒ったら負け もう何のこともない
まあ一応また質問があるならば
いろいろまた方法を説明いたしますが
怒りというのは人間の不幸そのものであります
人間というのは素晴らしく幸福で生きていてほしい
たとえ 1分 2分でも 30秒でも
困ったり悩んだりする必要はないんです
悔しがったりとか 負けた
こんちくしょうとか思ったりするのはもう不幸なんです
ですから 心は常に喜びを感じながら
すぐに常に明るく 常に楽しく生活していただきたいんです
まあ短い人生だから まあ苦しんだり悩んだりする必要はない
幸福で生きていられるんですから
それのためには我々の福を作ってくれる
その怒りだけは決して心の中に入らないようにすると
すぐその場で その瞬間で我々に幸福を味わうだろうと思います
同時に 怒りを収めることによって
確実に知恵が成長します
アンダースタンディングというものはどんどん成長します
物事がどんどん見えてきます
ものすごく見えてきます
ですから 知恵の道でもあります
ですが 怒るのは大馬鹿者だと言ったんだから
逆に怒らないようになる人はもう当たり前で
正真正銘の知識人であって賢者なんです
まあそういうことで 怒りが生まれないように努力しようということをしましょうということで終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]